cabbage and sausage as often as she can
Nadezhda Popova buys russian specialties
to bring a taste of home into her new
life in Paris she's been living in exile
for six months now the French
authorities assigned her family a very
small room way out in the suburbs and
two and a half hours from the Children's
School in Russia Goethe Papa who now
enjoys international renown was
considered an enemy of the state
she never tired of reminding the world
that thousands of people were exposed to
massive radiation in a nuclear accident
in 1957 long before the Chernobyl
disaster the incident occurred when a
container of nuclear waste exploded in a
power station in miok where the Soviets
manufactured plutonium for nuclear bombs
the effects were mostly swept under the
rug but Goethe pujas family was directly
affected Kozlova this is my grandmother
she were mobilized by Communist Party to
build a nuclear plant my Jack this is my
father he was a student of technical
school and he be immobilized by consume
all to liquidate consequences of nuclear
accident in 1957 at my oklet's kuttappa
Vaz grandmother and father died of
cancer according to scientists it was
the result of the accident they were not
the only victims he knows esque the
off-limits city in the Ural Mountains
near the Maya client
sir rates rose to extremely high levels
but no one was allowed to talk about it
after the dissolution of the Soviet
Union Goethe Baba sought compensation
for affected families she also
publicized the scandal in the
international media the Russian
authorities wanted to silence her she
was publicly accused of industrial
espionage the French office of the
International League for Human Rights
intervened and helped her leave Russia
unfortunately there are several cases in
which people like q-tip OVA had been
physically attacked or even murdered for
their work for human rights and that's
even more dangerous in a closed city
luck was asked which is far away from
Moscow and the international media but
Frances welcome was less than warm
Goethe Papa was suddenly one among the
increasing numbers of asylum seekers she
too had to wait four months to even get
an official appointment on some days
three four or five thousand people come
to our offices
there's no way to manage that we lack
funds and the political will and that's
just the way it is not des de puta
Baba's life in a cheap out-of-the-way
hotel doesn't make her feel safe in
France the Russian Secret Service has
made life hard for many exiled critics
of the government who tip OVA is certain
she's under surveillance
simply one person wrote me and I think
that this person can work for the
security system of Russian situation now
I think he's he tried to copulate with
me exactly for reason that they need
information what we she doesn't feel
welcome in France but she's not willing
to return to Russia where she would be
under threat people tell me that Nadia
you should be happy because you left
your nuclear hell and you're in Paris
but you know that the circumstances was
not so that I felt happy of course I
miss my euro
I miss my place and sometimes two nights
I I saw it in my dreams because it was
not my choice the European Court of
Human Rights in Strasbourg has just
ruled in her favor and condemned Russia
for refusing compensation to the miok
victims Goethe prova remains a thorn in
the side of the Russian state even in
exile